what is going on everybody and welcome
to my initial thoughts on the Amazon
echo dot version two so for me this is
actually my first echo device ever I
didn't buy the original one just because
I thought they were a little expensive
for what I needed I just I simply didn't
need another nice speaker so the dot two
the first thing about it is its size
it's it's pretty small and it can pretty
much be stuffed wherever you want in
your house and probably the best thing
about this device is the microphone on
it at least in my house I've got 1,800
square-foot house my office here is in
the back corner of my house and I can go
to the opposite side opposite corner of
my house and still engage with the
device without having to yell I've got
to raise my voice but I have to yell so
that's actually pretty impressive so
that was the first thing the second
thing is it does have a speaker on it
and it's actually on the bottom here and
surprisingly it works pretty well it
they like the speaker part kind of like
lifts up off of the ground just enough
to have the sound waves like bounce off
and you think that might sound kind of
weird but it actually doesn't so that's
that now for the price it was all it was
like $50 so when the echos first kind of
came out there was some hacks for how to
use like a Raspberry Pi to make your own
echo device and those were nice but at
50 dollars you're really not going to be
able to build your own echo device for
cheaper like this is as good as it's
gonna get so that's pretty impressive so
now some kind of downsides that I found
was one so with echo the skills are kind
of what makes the device so it comes
with some skills you can ask it to play
music and you can do a bunch of Amazon
things so if you're going to tie it to
your Amazon account like your Prime
account for example you can do that
really easily but the downside is if you
if you're trying to do other things
besides that if you go into the skills
like you would like maybe within your
app store with a phone you would expect
to find all kinds of really neat apps
well in the skill store that's just
really not the case now there could be a
whole lot of reasons for this I think
the main thing though is the skills
there's really no easy way to mana
heis the skills so with like phone apps
you can put ads on them or you can
charge like a dollar for the app and
that just that just works it makes it
easy for even small developers to kind
of enter into the market whereas with
the echo in the skills section of the
app there is no way to charge for a
skill so all the skills that you're
seeing there are just really basic where
there's really nothing there so they're
like facts or jokes or some news but
very light even on the news so that's
kind of a bummer so especially either
for a user or developer it's kind of
hard to get in there obviously you could
do things like have like audio ads or
you can have in-app purchases of some
kind also I've seen some people will
actually you know the echo is maybe
better thought of as a remote control
and that's it it doesn't do anything
else so then you tie that remote control
to something else some sort of web
service or even a phone app so you could
have it tied to some sort of mobile app
that you do charge for so there are
options but from what I'm seeing in the
skill store it's just not very popular
so the one thing that I really like and
I'll just demo it really quick is that
when you speak to the device you don't
have to pause after you say the devices
name which is one of the most annoying
things for me on the phone I think they
do it on the phone because the
microphone just can't always be on so it
like turns on then activates whereas
with Alexa
I don't really know maybe the microphone
really is just always on and listening
but on your like let's say on an Android
or even an Apple device so with Android
you'll say you know okay Google and then
you'll you'll have to like yes a wait a
second for like okay Google is start up
and go but that's okay I can understand
okay the microphones off but the thing
that really irritates me is like for
example when you're setting an event
with Google you'll set the event you'll
give it a title and then Google says is
this right do you want to save and but
if you answer it normally like if it
says do you want to save and you say
immediately yes so it's like do you want
to save yes if you do that it doesn't
work it doesn't register your yes right
and that's really annoying you have to
like wait and then say yes that's
annoying it's very clunky it's not
natural language so just
quickly let me pull this down here Alexa
play music shuffling your music Alexa
stop okay so it's it's really fast at UM
at the commands you don't have to have
this kind of arbitrary useless pause
when you you engage with it so anyway
those are just my initial thoughts I
think for fifty dollars you really can't
go wrong as long as you have something
you actually want to use it for so
probably one of the most popular things
is like the the Philips hue light bulbs
so you can get those lights and then
command the lights with your Alexa and
so that's pretty cool that's pretty
useful and also I've noticed that
sometimes when I say when I don't
actually mean to address this device it
doesn't actually I don't know how
quickly it's learning like when I'm just
talking about it it doesn't turn on but
then whenever I'm specifically
attempting to address it I must have
different voice or this is just totally
anecdotal but all on and off camera
I've been able to say the name and
either activate it or not depending on
actually what I really wanted so it's
kind of interesting when I first got it
it would activate just at anything
remotely similar to the name anyway so
yeah those are my initial thoughts I
hope that over time maybe the skill
store will evolve into something more
but I also think to an extent if you're
in it if you're a developer to yourself
which probably a lot of people on my
channel and watching this video are
there's a lot of like room for
development around this device so
Amazon's given you the platform but you
have to make something out of it and the
traditional kind of model of just make
an app slap some ads on it isn't
necessarily going to work but you have
some some real room to be pretty
creative and it makes something pretty
cool so anyways I'll leave that to you
all also on my channel I'll probably
come up with some tutorials there is a
Python API and stuff so we can work with
skills and create skills and stuff so
anyways be on the lookout for that
otherwise let me know what you guys
think of this new echo dot and basically
the entire echo line til next time